[Musique]
nous sommes le 18 octobre 1943 en pleine
période d'occupation allemande à la
poudrerie national duri pos actuel siège
du cio à hamon va se jouer l'une des
plus effroyables catastrophe de la
région 11h03 une première explosion
suivie de plusieurs autres d'une
violence inouïe se fait entendre jusqu'à
poitiers à tour des vitrines de magasins
explose le village voisin de vont
s'essouffler
bilan une centaine de morts 17 disparus
400 blessés dont 145 très grièvement
jean était alors âgé de 17 ans il
travaillait comme ouvrier ajusteur à la
poudrerie ses souvenirs restent intactes
au moment où je le veux la main pour
m'occuper à creuser des coussinets en
bronze là à ce moment là est arrivée
cette explosion on se demandait ce que
c'était le sol trembler sous le nez
tremblay a à se monter et descendre la
verrière m'est tombé dessus il verrier
en petits morceaux
la tête était plein de petits morceaux
de verre on sait je me suis retrouvé
dans le noir et vert d'un nuage
extrêmement importants comme un
championnat d' atomic à peu près on
entendait les gens râlaient on voyait
les explosions mais les lueurs et les
volets brandon enflammé tombait partout
on essayait de se mettre à l'abri d'une
poutre là
d'un arbre enfin on essayait joseph lui
était alors jeunes écoliers dans le
village voisin de mon alors ce 18
octobre c'était l'avion de la rentrée
des classes et nous les garçons nous
venions de rentrer dans l'école lorsque
l'explosion s'est produite donc un grand
souffle qui a fait voler les cahiers et
donc on l'a vu c'était nuage cette
immense nuage doit remonter dans le ciel
avec ce bruit infernal qui est de tôle
froissée
on a pas du tout de suite que c'était la
poudrerie qui venaient d'eux qu'ils
explosent et quoi un cratère de 40
mètres de diamètre et de 15 mètres de
profondeur tout est pulvérisée dans un
rayon de 850 m l'identification de
certains corps est impossible quand ils
ont été déchiquetés sur les causes de ce
spectacle d'apocalypse la presse locale
ne devra aucune explication occupation
oblige l'origine de cette catastrophe
est pourtant bien connue elle était même
prévisible en ce début de semaine les
allemands exigent que l'on des charges
d'un train en toute hâte
près de deux cents tonnes de coton
poudre un explosif d'autant plus
instable qu'il est bien trop sec
lorsque ces pelés premier wagon arrive
la première chose à faire c'est faire
des prélèvements pour vérifier le louis
delluc autant paulo et alors là c'est la
catastrophe
25 % des échantillons prélevés avait un
taux l'humilité de 5 à 12% alors que la
sécurité exige une humilité de 25%
minimum à ce degré de cécité le
frottement du coton sur le sol aps il
crie t on le vendredi
les poules riz et l'expérience refuse de
poursuivre le déchargement
le lundi on remet une nouvelle équipe en
place
le déchargement recommence à 11h03 cdh
explosion gigantesque donc les
conséquences pour la population seront
terribles et les survivants resteront
marqués à vie
j'ai vu les gens courir brûlé et vont
rentrer un spectacle que je décrirais
pas mais sa marque
c'était tellement le choc
on avait peur de beaucoup de gens et
puis c'est vraiment une stèle a été
érigée au centre du cimetière de monts
comme chaque année depuis 75 ans les
anciens viendront à nouveau se
recueillir ce 18 octobre pour qu'on
n'oublie jamais ce qui constitue l'une
des plus importante catastrophe qu'ait
connue la région